Napoleon certainly don't look like a
blood-crazed revolutionary the hood is a
bit sinister though if you don't mind my
saying it is sometimes hard to remember
how easy life was before the world
changed now people are starving in the
streets and those with the will to fight
back or imprisoned or worse where am I
in hell
we shall yield to nothing but bayonets
the life I had is gone your father was
an assassin oh no the world I knew with
it gave His life fight for the liberty
of all mankind
are you prepared to travel the Eagles
path boys ready rise amongst the
violence voted caste Grandmaster King
war done amongst the chaos honor your
father's memory I will find justice no
matter the cost
this is why I joined the Brotherhood for
revenge for redemption as you maximilian
de la tierra I will never work
lucky dosa
you used we we used one another
you're the only one who can save the
Brotherhood we can together
it happens tonight please you want to
protect me
or to help you
nicely done my friend
if you don't have the stomach for
revenge then I don't need your help
we've been betrayed from within Inspira
see intrigue I have to do this myself
make history Assassin's Creed unity
pre-order now for the explosive chemical
revolution mission get a season pass
save 30% on 8 hours of new content
includes a new campaign more missions
and weapons and a new downloadable game
pre-order now available November 11th